[музика]
Усім привіт з вами пані Ліда і
ведмежатко бо Привіт Привіт
на попередніх заняттях ми вже з вами
вивчили багато літер і Давайте спробуємо
їх повторити за допомогою пісеньки А раз
ось послухайте а б в г ґ д е е є ж з її
як і Щека далі ми будемо добавляти кожен
раз нову літеру яку ми будемо вивчати а
сьогодні у нас новенька літера
ведмежатко Поглянь це літера називається
літера
л і звук
л давайте повторимо разом
л звук м коли ми його вимовляємо то нам
щось там заважає наче якась перешкода
там є це приголосний звук приголосний
звук
л
ось давайте Подивимось як буквочка л
виглядає вона наче відставила собі так
ніжку у бік спробуймо її написати
пальчиком Гаразд візьмемо пальчик
підіймемо і
напишемо можемо просто ось такі дві
палички зверху і донизу і ще раз зверху
і донизу наче якась гірка трішки нагадую
якусь буквочку яку ми вже з вами вчили
начебу квочка А правда але без вперед
Сьогодні у нас буквочка л Не плутайте її
з іншими буквочками тому що буква е дуже
всіх любить адже з неї починається слово
любов
і всі букви відповідають їй взаємністю
любити це означає ведмедику допомагати
підтримувати один одного і буквочка л
завжди усім допомагають а ще з літери л
починаються такі слова як
л Любисток така лікарська рослина або
л літера просто ті літери які ми з вами
вивчаємо або
л Лаванда теж така красива квітка з
фіолетовими маленькими квіточками вона
дуже має приємний аромат і заспокійливий
а також і інші слова Давайте подумаємо
які ведмедику підкажеш нам
лу ластівка Так це така красива пташка
вірно А ще
листя вірно молодець ведмедик А ще друзі
підказуйте і ви в лампа вірно допомагає
нам навчатися Та підсвічую нам дещо
вірно молодці а ось послухайте вірш і
знайдіть у ньому звук
л і літеру Л ліс густий зелений ріс в
тому лісі живе лис букви ли собі шукав
згодом лис ученим став та найбільше
любить лис букву Л як і цвіль ліс друзі
чи почули про кого був Цей віршик
хто там головні герої ти почув ведмедику
я почув там був Лис і ліс вірно друзі
правильно ведмедик каже і про ліс і про
лиса Давайте ми з вами зараз ці слова
запишемо на дошці Ось у нас є
нам вже знайома літера и
лист і Оста літера с і звук с і в нас
утворилося слово ведмедику
мис вірно від буквочки до буквочки Ми
так і навчимося читати утворилося слово
лист А якщо Ми змінимо посередині
голосний
у нас утворюється зовсім інше слово Ану
зверніть увагу давайте прочитаємо
[музика]
ліс вірно з лиса перетворився ліс от Як
цікаво виходить але знаєте друзі що ліс
називають легенями нашої планети А чому
Як ти думаєш ведмедик
Я не знаю добре я розповім вам тому що
ліс виробляє дуже багато кисню таке
повітрячко хороше яким ми дихаємо і ліс
- це дерева правда ж тому ліс наш друг а
ще друзі наші книжки
зошити все що ви маєте з листочків
зроблене але листочки зроблені з дерев
тобто з лісу
уявляєте як це цікаво і папір якраз яким
ми користуємося роблять з деревини А
зараз відгадайте на що перетворюється
вода узимку
ведмедику Ану будемо на що може
перетворитися водичка коли вона замерзає
як це називається
не здогадався
А друзі здогадались це лід і давайте
напишемо це слово у нас на дошці Ми
змінимо останню буквочку і утворимо
слово Давайте прочитаємо його
[музика]
лід правильно молодці Ми вже навчилися з
вами читати коротенькі слова добре
А зараз відгадайте ще одну загадку у
людини руки і ноги а у тваринки що що у
нашого медвежатка
[музика]
лапи вірно лапи абсолютно вірно і у
слові ли лапи теж є звук л а Підкажіть
мені будь ласка чим можна підсвітити
собі дорогу
що у нас є таке помічне для цього
л
ліхтарик вірно в молоці а подумайте яка
пора року починається на
л ведмедику ти знаєш ой здається я знаю
знаю це літо Літо літо невірно м літо а
Підкажіть мені будь ласка А який є такий
фрукт він жовтого кольору Але такий
киселенький на смак
як він називається є такого не їв Я
такого не люблю
але він дуже-дуже корисний особливо при
застуді як називається цей фрукт
жовтого кольору і кисленький в
лимон абсолютно вірно молодці а зараз
нам час трішки почитати деякі склади
ведмедику ось ти посади А ми зараз
діткам складемо деякі склади які ви
можете вже прочитати перша літера у нас
буде L і звук
л
другу літеру ми поставимо нашого ватажка
літеру А
так і третю літеру поставимо
як називається ця літера
літера к або звуки і зможемо прочитати
слово а слово утворилося
лак Давайте ви прочитаєте А ми
послухаємо з ведмедиком
лак молодці а тепер ми можемо змінити
одну літеру останню і утвориться слово
інше А яке Прочитайте будь ласка
[музика]
куди можна залазити вірно молодці а якщо
ми заберемо останню літеру і поставимо
іншу
утвориться
лад вірно молодці друзі отак по черзі ми
з вами і будемо вчитися читати А скажіть
мені будь ласка чи знаєте ви якісь імена
які починаються з літери л і звуку л
ведмедику ти чув такий імена здається є
одне знаю
і я Мені здається одне знаю А яка ж це
ім'я Друзі Ну Пригадайте як мене звати
так
л Ліда вірно А ще є дуже красиве ім'я
л Ліна
Лариса
л Леонід А ще є слово Оленка і у ньому
теж є звук л
ще красиво дуже ім'я для хлопчика знаєш
яке м Лаврін є таке ім'я гаразд Ну що ж
а зараз час на гру Давайте ви приготуєте
долоньки А ми з ведмедиком будемо
називати слова А ваше завдання плеснути
у долоні тоді коли ви почуєте у слові
звук л увага Нумо починаємо
лисиця
ведмедику плескаємо чи ні в лисиця
звісно долоньки готові плескаємо молодці
л ластівка
[музика]
Так є плескіт молодці малина
теж дитина
немає у слові дитина звуку
л калина
є супер молодці
лимон
підказала вам вірно ми плескаємо стіл
є Супер котик
[музика]
немає молодці гаразд Ну що ж ми гарно з
вами побавилися у гру А ми з вами
прощаємося На все добре До нових
зустрічей па-па
[музика]
Привіт друзі Усім привіт з вами пані
Настя істинка ми сьогодні з вами
трошечки поспіваємо
Приготуйте ваші ручки будемо робити
деякі рухи і пальчики і ваш ротик звісно
ми будемо співати Ми сьогодні заспіваємо
і вивчимо пісеньку про котика і мишок
які не давали котику спати давайте з
вами вивчимо рухи і слова ходить котик
дуже обережно ступає та покажіть як він
так помаленьку ступає
давайте трошечки понявкаємо мяу мяу Ну і
починаємо
ходить котик по кімнаті показуємо Які в
нього м'якесенькі лапки в нього
тапочки на ваті тому він так тихенько
ходить позіхавай
душ позіхніть щось я сумний дуже як він
як мене чи коли сонні ми так потираємо
очками а під ліжком нірка нірка
звідти мишка
зирка-зирка-зирк туди
цирк сюди де котячії сліди так супер і
тепер знову котики йде
виліз котик на подушку і чухаємо себе за
вушком
водить лапкою за вушком
вигинає спинку порухайте трошки спинкою
ось так
ляжу на
годинку
Гей ви миші
тихо-тихо бо вам буде
лихо лихо кіт не спить а
слухала так і робимо такі вушка як в
котика
наставляє
вуха і знов робимо
мяу мяу мяу
увагу
мяу
мяу-м'яв чудово Ось така пісенька
Давайте спробуємо повторити її від
початку і до кінця з рухами готові
готові чудово давайте ходить котик по
кімнаті
в нього
тапочки на ваті
[музика]
позіхавай дуже
щось я сумний дуже а під ліжком нірка
нірка звідти
мишка-зирка-зирка зирк всюди цирк туди
де котячії сліди
виліз котик на подушку
водить лапкою за вушком
починає спинку
ляжу на годинку
Гей ви миші
тихо-тихо бо вам буде
лихо лихо кіт не спить а слугуха
наставляє вуха
няв
няу-мяу-мяу
мяу-мяу-мяу
молодці поплескайте собі
чудово поспівали
молодці Друзі Ну а тепер нам час
прощатися па-па були раді вас бачити
[музика]